there have been more civilians killed in
Haiti than Ukraine in the first months
of 2023 according to the United Nations
world food program
powerful gangs are battling overmatch
police in the streets of the capital
Puerto Prince
in the middle the population
lives in City Soleil an epicenter of the
violence her stepfather was shot dead on
her doorstep now she's worried about her
daughters
look at all the bullet holes at my door
and my ceiling I ask for help so my
daughters can go to the school I don't
want them to be at the streets exposed
to the criminals they are girls
sexual violence is Rife in Haiti gangs
use rape to cow and control the
population in their domains
and their grip is only tightening the
United Nations estimates that 80 percent
of the capital is run by criminal groups
it's affecting access to food half of
all Haitians now face acute food
insecurity more than in Somalia and
Afghanistan says the world food program
famine itself has arrived in City Soleil
the red on the tape indicates that this
child is severely malnourished I would
say that people have been starved in
quarter prints it's definitely been the
case here that armed groups have been
isolating parts of Porter prints they've
been using Siege tactics
and that's entirely unacceptable in
rural areas what's going on is that
these gangs are fighting for farmland
and they're farting fighting for the
food sources
that includes Haiti's Bread Basket the
artibonate affecting the food supply
even more
Merchant adania Pierce was kidnapped on
her way to Market
they told us they were going to kill us
they didn't give us food or water for
days and they blindfolded us it was so
tight that it hurt our eyes the money
that I borrowed is now worrying me a lot
people who lend me money ask me now to
pay them back they took a loan at the
bank for me now I stay at home I don't
know what to do
recently heavy rains have also struck
Haiti turning thousands out of their
homes a fresh blow to a country already
suffering
John Holman Al Jazeera